I mean even after Trump was elected you
saw a bunch of these media outlets
saying oh well we need to go into middle
America and talk to people and figure
out why this happened and it's like well
you could have done that before
[Music]
welcome to trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constance and kissing and
this is a show for you if you're bored
with people arguing on the Internet of
the subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry you don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts as you can
see we're not in our normal environment
we're recording this of the Battle of
ideas which many of you are going to be
so come and say hello if you around and
our brilliant guest this week is a
journalist and the co-founder of
subversive
Emily Molly welcome to trigonometry okay
good to be here and it's good to have
you thank you so much for coming to talk
to us for anybody who doesn't know who
you are tell us a little bit about who
are you how are you where you are what
has been the journey that brings you to
this very chair oh wow okay so I'm an
independent journalist i co-founded some
verses and I've been doing a lot of
on-the-ground reporting around the
around the world in the u.s. I cover
certain topics one of my main focuses is
social movements so within the US I've
been covering sort of the rise of white
nationalism an tyfa and then around the
world I've also been covering things
like the Hong Kong protests the yellow
bus movement and then also the Catalan
independence protests and you mentioned
earlier when we were talking just before
that you were you were covering the
Donald Trump election campaign in 2016
you were not a credentialed journalist
at the time yeah so you had to wait in
line for six hours and do you find
yourself chatting to people and finding
out what their views were and as part of
that you could kind of see the his
election coming yeah so that's quite an
interesting thing about actually
journalism where you actually talk to
people it's quite unusual these days
isn't it yeah and it really eliminated
to me just how much of the press in
general kind of sits in a bubble and in
you know you could call it an echo
chamber where they're promising the same
ideas off of each other and they're not
real
getting the sort of real world view of
normal people so I followed pretty much
all of the candidates in 2016 and by
just sitting in line standing in line
with people and chatting with them about
what they care about their main issues
you kind of get a feel for what they
what they pay attention to what they
don't care about like a lot of the Trump
supporters I know I was didn't really
care about what the press was saying
about Trump in fact I think it made them
liked him more but yet it was also just
being able to see how unenthused a lot
of people were about Hillary Clinton as
well seeing how like extremely enthused
a lot of people were about Bernie
Sanders and then you kind of had sort of
I guess
lukewarm sort of enthusiasm for other
Republican candidates so yeah it was a
really interesting experience talking to
people and Emily you see we're talking
about how there's this disconnect
between the mainstream media and the
people and it mentioned really were
famous and that they didn't predict and
they didn't see Trump coming why do you
think they're so detached is it because
they come from one part of society or
well that's a really good question I
think a lot of journalists now come from
a lot of the same background you know a
lot of them go to school for journalism
and get taught by the same people and
not everyone goes to school of
journalism journalism but I think the
more you have people who spend more of
their time around journalists and this
is another thing that's pretty true
about Twitter is like a lot of Twitter
is just journalists talking to other
journalists and yeah I mean it is people
talking and reaffirming each other's
beliefs and when you have people
disagreeing with their few points and
opinions and there must be something
wrong with that person because everyone
else and in their bubble agrees with
them so I think it is a I mean even
after Trump was elected you saw a bunch
of these media outlets saying oh well we
need to go into middle America and talk
to people and figure out why this
happened and it's like well you could
have done that before
and that maybe you wouldn't have looked
so what did they miss so you talked
about people's enthusiasm but what was
some of the issues on the campaign
trails that worth using Bernie
supporters why was Hillary not
interesting to people why was Trump so
popular with the people that you talk to
I think a lot of it had to do with
economic issues not so much social
issues a lot of the people who were more
Bernie supporting the younger people
were more interested in social issues as
well as student debt which is just a
huge crushing problem for American
people in America right now but for
Donald Trump supporters specifically I
do believe economic issues and then some
social issues like addiction like the
opioid epidemic a lot of people just
think the status quo was putting them in
these situations where nothing was
improving nothing was really changing
and how do you change things you get
somebody who's a total outsider and in
charge and I think that's really what
they wanted and you know it's there was
sort of this attitude towards the press
where a lot of people felt like they
weren't being represented fairly and so
when you see them misrepresenting Donald
Trump or the things that he said they
felt very you know they felt a lot more
in touch with what he was saying and how
he was treated than other other
candidates and what's interesting about
the mainstream media is that they've
made mistakes and you know in a way we
all make mistakes of course we do but
what seems baffling with them is that
they don't seem to have learned from
their mistakes in fact they just seem to
be doubling down
oh my god yeah CNN is like the perfect
example of that but uh you have to kind
of look at their incentives at that
point too they had the Trump bump during
the 2016 election and then after he was
elected his position
[Laughter]
but yeah they saw that it was profitable
and so they they doubled down they kept
talking Trump Trump Trump and you know a
lot of other outlets followed suit with
that it got more clicks it got more
bigger it got a bigger audience and I
don't know I just it's not sustainable
though at a certain point people do want
to hear about real issues again and
unfortunately a lot of real issues have
been going uncovered or just have been
minimized because everyone is so focused
on what Trump tweeted and do you think
part of the problem as well is that the
media and I've seen it as because I've
worked in radio is that the media are
terrified because their traditional ways
of funding themselves monetizing the
evaporating yeah absolutely think that's
the case because now it's it's more of a
click economy and we've seen that
failing you see a lot of media outlets
in the u.s. digital outlets failing and
laying people off and being bought up
like consolidating and I really think
you know you put your eggs in the
advertising basket rather than focusing
I want your community what your audience
wants and will support you for which I I
think is why so many more people are
turning to the subscription-based
options and yeah there just needs to be
better options out there for people do
you think that's not partly a problem
though like we have a lot of
subscription-based services in this
country and what I always feel is it
forces people you know people have
limited amount of money so you end up
like buying a subscription to the one
newspaper that you agree with yeah and
they just keep feeding you the same
stuff that you like and then you end up
in even more a bubble than you wouldn't
normally would have done otherwise known
as The Guardian The Guardian actually
asked for donations I'm actually I'm
actually talking about some of the
newspapers I've heard yeah you know the
Telegraph to spectate if you want to
read a lot of that you have to pay and
you know if you if you're not going to
buy a subscription to 10 different
outlets which most people are not you
end up with the guy we know not the
guide in The Spectator view or the
telegraphy or the whatever you
all great newspapers please keep getting
my articles into your newspapers but but
you know I'm saying yeah yeah and that's
where I think like one of the issues is
just how yeah I think it's just it needs
to almost be completely reworked as an
industry I don't believe in putting
important news or just news in general
behind a paywall
but if people want like
behind-the-scenes content or like if
they want more in-depth analysis on
something that takes more time it takes
more work and I think some people are
willing to throw down $3 $5 a month for
some of those extras so 30 pounds for a
mug you never know you know with the
clickbait thing is interesting to meet
and to get your perspective on ER I feel
like the mainstream media they're dying
so quickly that they are desperate for
clicks they have now become the
clickbait a medium and it's us who are
doing new media that are actually doing
long-form content in our case or
on-the-ground reporting in your case
really giving people a completely
different view of what's happening do
you think this is going to continue do
you think the mainstream media will at
some point go actually no we've gone too
far we need to start doing things the
way because their brand really it's like
substantive reporting historically
yeah and they're killing their own brand
by doing this click based upon they yeah
I think it just needs to be completely
reworked the media landscape and how it
funds itself and how it I think a lot of
like a lot of newspapers at least in the
u.s. I think like the New York Times
specifically has kind of ostracized a
lot of their own audience by by doing
ridiculous clickbait or yeah and I think
at that point they need to take a look
at what they started as and what they've
turned into and kind of figure out how
to how to return to their roots of
actual journalism rather than telling
people what to think but I'm not sure if
they're I think you see a lot of outlets
who are taking taking cues from new
media doing long-form doing podcasts and
trying to spread spread their content
that way I don't know if
it's sustainable for them to do that as
well I think I think we're just seeing
in general people are gravitating
towards new new ways of digesting
information and how they find it and
yeah it does cause the problem of echo
chambers again still but yeah you have
sort of a saturated media market with
commentators and I don't think
mainstream news outlets can necessarily
compete with with like long-form YouTube
channels or podcasts like Joe Roku's Joe
Rogan for example of like pulls millions
millions for his podcast a lot of people
go to him for information rather than
because I'd rather hear Joe Rogan just
shoot the [ __ ] with people they're not
gonna get that from media outlet so they
try to like they try to do things like
podcasts and long-form discussions but
I'm not sure if it's going to take off
the same way as some of the other
channels would and Emily it seems to me
that we live in an age where people are
more distrustful of mainstream media
than ever yeah it's not because of the
internet and it's just hyperbolized that
or is it actually that people more and
more just switching off and think to
themselves you know what i do not want
to engage with this anymore i think
there's sort of a combination of if
people see something in the news that
they know isn't true then it's kind of a
disillusionment factor they're like I
know for me specifically I used to take
when I was younger I've kind of took the
news at face value because you're you
trust them to tell you the truth and
then when I started covering things and
then seeing things in person and then
seeing it reported in a totally
different way than I was like okay well
I guess I can't trust it anymore and I
think especially when you have
misrepresentations of what people say
you lose a lot of people that way but I
also think there's sort of this this
bias towards you know whether it's
partisan media where people don't want
to believe it or yeah but I do think for
the most part a lot of outlets have
ended up shooting themselves in the foot
just by reporting
misinformation or disinformation and
it's also the style of conversation I
mean I remember the Kathy Newman Jordan
Peterson it you know if you caught that
yeah and the channel for argument if
you're a producer there's go look we did
this great thing we got twenty million
views on YouTube isn't that brilliant I
mean we've just got a huge audience that
we've attracted but most people could
watch that we'll never watch a Cathy new
but yeah and do it ever again that's a
perfect example ya know and exactly it's
like they'll probably look at that and
be like wow look how much controversy
that generated it got us a bunch of
views you know bad press is still press
but again they're not realizing how much
of how much of the trust they lost from
their audience by doing that kind of
thing and tell us about some verses
which is the organization that you
co-founded what is the the antidote that
you're trying to offer what's your angle
if you like we just pretty much try to
report straightforward facts with
context that like that shows what
matters in a situation we don't we don't
cut up interviews to make people look
stupid we don't do combative or advocacy
journalism we pretty much will interview
people and let them say their thing for
the most part like well obviously fact
check if somebody is spouting nonsense
but at the same time if you I think
there's some merit to hearing people lie
and even if they don't know they're
they're lying if they're if there's if
they're just basically talking about
talking points for example like a lot of
protests we cover a lot of people will
go back just the talking points that
they hear in the media and stuff like
that but there are some other situations
where we can point specifically it to
somebody lying and saying this is
actually what happened but we're
basically just trying to come back with
an approach that gives people
information to make up their own minds
sounds like a gateway to the far right
and on that note that is something you
have been looking at haven't you looking
at the far right and is there a rise in
the far right now very much one of the
narratives have been parroted in the
mainstream media is that we have seen a
rise in white nationalism the far right
is this true particularly in America I
would say in America there I don't think
they ever really went away but I think
we're seeing them more more active in
rallies and recently it's it's been kind
of a hyper focus of of some some outlets
just saying oh you know this is far
right this is extremism this is white
nationalism and I think people really do
a disservice to to those actual problems
when they will pretty much throw the
label out on anything that they kind of
suspect of being like alt right if they
even if they don't really know what that
means there are a lot of issues in the
u.s. with white nationalism wait
separatism and just white supremacy in
general but I don't think it's as huge
of an epidemic as a lot of people try to
make it out
I think after you know there is a lot of
it is reactionary where there were like
white live matter white lives matter
rallies that were white nationalist
groups coming out and just trying to
almost be into agonistic a lot of them
do a lot of them do just want to cause
controversy and hope that Antipa will
show up so they can get into a street
fight with them and it's worked and so I
don't know I think they're getting a lot
more attention than they should and I
think they're actually probably they're
probably finding it easier to recruit
with people throwing around terms like
alt-right white nationalists because
they're making it sound somebody who
isn't necessarily that extreme will say
oh well they're calling me a white
nationalist anyway maybe I should like
maybe I should go with that group that
they might not be all that bad anyway so
people are being pushed into it as well
I think by using the terms irresponsibly
I do think it is a recruiting tool and I
so we both work in comedy which is very
woke and you know social justice all the
rest of it now a lot of people have told
me that Donald Trump is a white
supremacist he's a white supremacist
president is a he's a sign that that we
have a rise of the Nazis in the US would
you agree and your opinions on this
because he sees a narrative that is
being pushed I hear it all the time so
yeah people equating the the make
America great again hat to the KKK hood
mm-hmm I think that is a gross
oversimplification of I don't doubt that
like I don't know I don't know him
personally but I also think I don't
think he's gotten I don't think he's
even been endorsed by a whole lot of
white nationalist groups because too
extreme there are some things that he
said that people will try to jump on and
be like oh look he's supporting my
supremacist he's supporting white
nationalists but there's there's things
that he does that white nationalists and
Weiss process don't agree with like
mainly things with Israel but yeah I
don't know I think it's a really gross
oversimplification to call him a white
supremacist or a white nationalist
alright and what about on the other side
because as you say the Irish she's
around white supremacy United States
there's residues of that that is
happening you do see them to showing up
armed and being violent and as you say
hoping for antifa to turn up but what
about on the other side what about
auntie fur what are they doing what is
what is your reading of them because you
were reported on this quite a bit so
it's interesting cuz like I've covered
aunt Eva in various countries and the
u.s. one is kind of well I want to say
I'll try to be nice
disjointed and disorganized and I don't
know I don't know exactly what they're
they're aiming to achieve but the ways
that they're doing it by intimidating
people harassing people I don't think
that is
an effective way to do whatever they're
trying to do there's I don't know I
think a lot of people are searching for
meaning right now because they don't
have either they don't have much going
on in their life to give them meaning
and when you put a cause in front of
someone you say hey let's be
anti-fascist like yeah of course like
why wouldn't you be an anti-fascist
nobody nobody in their right mind would
be Pro fascism I believe but when these
kind of movements get co-opted by people
who have either I guess I guess I'm
still trying to be nice but I want to
say issues where they they really
succumbed to mob mentality and
harassment vandalism of people who
aren't against them even yeah I think in
the u.s. especially they have some
issues and we see some of their violence
we've had and II know on the show for
example do you think their terrorist
organization 94 I think you have
individual members who are using tactics
that you could call terrorism to achieve
a political political end I don't even
think they can be considered an
organization in themselves because just
because you fly a flag doesn't mean
you're part of an organization but I do
think there are individuals who are
using extremely extremely like harsh
tactics to intimidate people to cause
harm to people and I would call those
probably extra terrorism if they're
trying to achieve a specific political
mean means but again I don't even know
if they know what they want as far as
demands or what what their goals are
well Ana kiss being unsure about me
a lot of Auntie far even anarchists I
think a lot of them are trend like a lot
of them will try to be communist or
socialist I don't even know if they
understand a lot of the the systems that
they endorse but it's kind of just a
trendy thing for a lot of a lot of
people it seems and it does seem to be
something that people put on a Twitter
bio anti-fascist yeah and they're not
you said it sounds good it sounds like
something that you should be we've all
anti-fascist on right yeah I would
assume so
the problem is what happened with things
like Charlize Vil what people think that
there is a purpose for this movement yes
I think there are specific things people
look at like Charlotte's velour they see
if somebody ran over a bunch of
protesters and you know that's that's
another thing it's just you have these
certain situations that will give
legitimacy to move to people who think
this movement is is a good cause and in
a lot of ways are a lot of people's
hearts are in the right place but the
tactics that are being used aren't
necessarily effective or for the good of
whatever movement they're trying to push
[Music]
so we interviewed Minister Chen and it
was a brilliant interview and she was
saying actually it's very very difficult
to find out what's happening in Hong
Kong because unless you're on the ground
then things become distorted and
obviously it's difficult to get what the
real message is out of China so could
you explain to us what is actually
happening in Hong Kong okay so these
protests started back in I believe end
of May or early June when a extradition
bill was proposed and the extradition
bill was a lot of people in Hong Kong
saw that as a veiled attempt to be able
to extradite people from Hong Kong to
mainland China and just with with people
feeling like China's been encroaching on
the rights of Hong Kongers it sort of
broke the camel's back that was sort of
the final straw for a lot of people and
so they started protesting and it's
funny because what could have been put
to rest very easily they ended up
withdrawing the bill for
anyway not too long ago but if they had
done that months ago this wouldn't have
spiraled into what it is now now they
have five demands there's been
incredibly harsh police brutality
there's been basically every single week
there's been protests and they've had up
to up to half a million people marching
in the streets in pouring rain in
extremely hot weather and it's just
incredible determination on the part of
these protesters incredible organization
and it's funny because you're starting
to see other movements take tactics from
the Hong Kong protesters because of how
effective they've been in just staying
unified and staying on message I've
never covered anything like it it's
extremely well-organized and it's not
the kind of solidarity or unification
you see in a lot of movements a lot of
people will try to co-opt it and push
their own messages but they have their
five demands now and the job would so
they want full withdrawal of the
extradition bill which finally just
recently happened they want dual
universal suffrage for the Legislative
Council and I think one of the other I
can't remember what the other government
body is but they want to be able to
choose their own leaders rather than
having the Chinese Communist Party
choose who they can elect from they want
they want the classification of rioters
to be dropped because basically in order
to protest in Hong Kong you have to you
have to apply for a letter of no
objection and if you get that letter of
no objection then you can protest but
what they dried tried to do to stop the
protest was not not issue any of the
letters no objection so if they don't
then they get charged with writing the
riot right Church can put you in prison
for up to ten years so they want the
classification of writing of riots to be
dropped they want amnesty for the the
arrested protesters how many is that
I think that's out and the last one is
they want an independent investigation
into the police for the conduct that
they've been using they've been using
expired - yes they've been using
excessive force they've been firing -
your gas an enclosed space
which is extremely dangerous they've
been targeting journalists when they
enacted the anti mask law the idea was
that you're not allowed to be wearing a
mask when you're protesting but they
made they were supposed to make
exceptions for people who needed masks
for work which would be journalists
however they were still abusing that and
they were even people who weren't
protesting they would arrest them for
wearing masks or they would intimidate
them they told journalists that they
couldn't wear masks and threaten to rip
them off and yeah it's just really no no
accountability on the behalf of the
police and basically the government has
been running defense for them and trying
to justify all of the tactics they've
been using and it's it's just it's it's
kind of gone out of control the public
in Hong Kong has sort of turned against
like one of the main things social
movement needs is public support and one
of the the best ways to squash a
movement is to turn the public against
them it's extremely hard for them to do
that when the police are also harassing
intimidating and brutalizing regular
citizens not just protesters so even if
they do try to put undercover police
into the protests and have them either
beat people up throw Molotov cocktails
or cause general chaos the the
overwhelming majority of the public
support is still with the Hong Kong
protesters like there was one instance
there they were trying to kettle the
protesters and basically instead of
because they couldn't run away they were
basically were basically cornered and a
bunch of residents opened their doors to
let them into the building and hide them
you don't really see that and any other
protest anywhere else it's really
incredible and Chinese government have
accused you know the protesters of
violence of you know you know vandalism
all the rest of it is this true is it
the vandalism is interesting because
it's very targeted it's mostly targeted
at pro Chinese companies China companies
that come out against the protest and
then
companies that are owned by the mainland
I'm sure there's been a couple here and
there that I think they have mistakenly
targeted some and they actually will
release an apology
which is really sweet and yeah there has
been violence where people who will go
and either they've had issues with
people growing and taking photos of the
faces of protesters and of course in
that situation a lot of people fear
retribution from the government so
they'll ask if they don't get the person
to delete it off their phone they'll
usually beat them up they'll yeah a
little spray paint them same thing if
they find people trying to tear down the
Lenin walls and and people who have run
and almost tried to run over protesters
actually some people have run over
protesters and they pull them out of the
car and beat them up so yeah there has
been violence from the protesters as
well and how do you see this going
because it seems that it's been
organically what you said happening and
growing and mushrooming surely China
great human rights record I'm not gonna
let this go and keep growing because it
undermines their authority yes and I
think it's you can't really put this
genie back in the bottle at this point
so I do think they're waiting for
something and then they're gonna you
know they're gonna come down pretty hard
on it there's various ways they can do
that a lot of people have been
speculating already because at the the
people's liberation army barracks
there's been footage of people within
the barracks dressed up like protesters
running around as if they're training to
like be undercover protesters there's
also the emergency ordinance powers that
can pretty much deport foreigners
journalists and it will enact all kinds
of it's basically martial law at that
point the the anti mask law was part of
an emergency ordinance so it kind of
shows that they're not opposed to using
that so I really I'm worried it is going
to be a pretty brutal crackdown
and that's why a lot of the protesters
are asking for help from other countries
but I mean they're up against an
extremely powerful government and I
don't really know how well that's going
to go and what was it like for you being
on the ground as a foreign journalist in
this kind of environment
you kind of get royalty treatment which
I am not used to as a journalist among
protesters
it's wild like they really take care of
the press there I'm sure I also had sort
of Western privilege if they saw I was
from the from the US they're like oh
thank you thank you for being here and
thank you for covering this people
always come up to you offering you water
and food and if it starts raining
they'll come over and put your umbrella
over you until you can get your rain
cover out it's they they really know how
to how to use public opinion to support
their cause and again it's such a home
and these people are just very nice
extremely polite so yeah it's it's I
guess I feel spoiled every time I go to
cover things and they you know it's
they're really just grateful people are
paying attention to it they really want
especially America they just want some
help and it's it's it's amazing that you
say that the way they treat because
they're grateful because I suppose they
realize it they put their lives on the
line here mm-hmm and I mean that's the
definition of bravery and then streaming
that's it and you know the nice they are
to the more welcoming the more likely
there is their message is to spread but
it's not looking like a lot of Western
countries are supporting them no but I
think there's a lot of economic
interests in Hong Kong so I think once
those things start to be for end then
Western countries will start paying a
bit more attention but I think right now
a lot of countries are just not having
this it's kind of crazy like in the u.s.
you have a couple couple lawmakers who
will pay attention and support their
express their support for the protests
however there isn't a whole lot more
being done the US Congress is trying to
pass the Hong Kong human rights and
democracy Act but that's kind of just
like a broad condemning of human rights
violations the other one that they're
trying to pass is the protect act which
would it would ban the exporting of
non-lethal crowd control rounds to Hong
Kong because of it being misused so
those are just two things that are kind
of being done but I don't know how much
else is gonna be done unless money
starts getting involved it's quite
interesting that Donald Trump is very
much at odds with China and has been
since she started running but it's not
an issue that he's talked much about is
it no in fact it was kind of strange
because a lot of people in Hong Kong
will you know express their their want
for Donald Trump to do something and
then on the Chinese National Day October
1st which was one of the largest
protests in Hong Kong they called it the
National Day of Mourning
Donald Trump tweeted congratulations to
President Xi Jinping on 70 years and
it's everyone is kind of like
disappointed at that point it's like
you're congratulating Xi Jinping on a
communist regime it's like and well
meanwhile all of these you have a lot of
protesters in Hong Kong like waving
American flags and supporting expressing
support for Donald Trump or expressing
support for the u.s. in general and it's
like I don't want to I don't want them
to they're already disappointed I just
want to tell them like don't hold your
breath for him to get involved he's not
really paying attention he said
something the other week saying oh well
you know it's not as bad as it was at
the beginning it's like you're obviously
not paying attention because it's way
worse than it was at the beginning so
yeah I don't know if he's gonna end up
doing anything about it I guess you know
he ran on the platform of America first
battle with China is of America's
interest as opposed to Hong Kong so
people in Hong Kong Hong Kong shouldn't
hold their breath now I don't think I
don't think he's gonna do much I was
gonna ask you about the yourse the style
of reporting that you do which is a lot
of is on the ground kind of I'm here
there's an argument to be made that this
kind of I don't know if it's do they
call it gonzo journalism is that did I
just invent that in my there is a there
is a gonzo aspect but I think gonzo is a
little more I think there's a little
more advocacy in gonzo journal
well you with your style of journalism
is there not an argument to say that by
its very definition like eyewitness
testimony is extremely unobjective right
the person who is right there in the
moment when something happens actually
doesn't have a broader objective
perspective do you see what I mean
before I was doing this I was mostly
doing raw footage and the thing about
that is you really can't lie if you just
let let it play out
you trust your eyes more than you trust
people telling you what's going on I
think that's kind of what our audience
appreciates is that we just let the
footage and the people do the talking
and not telling our using our own
conjecture or own analysis to sort of
push an agenda or anything like that and
because honestly like at the end of the
day that was really kind of what
disillusioned me with the media was
seeing something with my own eyes and
then hearing it reported in a totally
different way so a lot of people say oh
you know it's boring it's very
monotonous and stuff like that but a lot
of people really appreciate that and you
know are willing to take a little bit of
monotony if it means they get the truth
and we see now with these protests with
you know Hong Kong Catalunya that yellow
this universe absolutely in France and
it just seems to be there just seems to
be these uprisings is this is there more
of this happening or we just becoming
more aware of it I think this point in
time right now there's a lot going on
and everything is due to different
circumstances but at the same time I
feel like we see it a lot more just
because of how technology has progressed
and we're able to see on Twitter the
protests happening in Lebanon and Iraq
and like all of these other places and a
lot of people do want to draw a
connection and be like oh it's just the
whole world is going to [ __ ] and it's
you know there's some truth to that
because there's all kinds of you know
there are individual circumstances in
these different countries that have made
these happen and then you kind of just
have to look at just a global scale of
some of the trends you know a lot of it
has to do with a standard of living
unemployment economy and
you know a lot of people are are not
happy with their governments for
different reasons like the the reason
that yellow vests are unhappy with the
government is different than why people
in Lebanon are unhappy with their
government and so you kind of have to
look at those individual situations too
and do you think the reason they've been
able to mobilize so effectively is
because of social media whereas before
it would be so much more difficult to
communicate to mobilize to organize but
now with social media it's no super easy
with social media however there are a
lot of movements that still have issues
with things like Facebook taking it down
their events see all of us in particular
that's why I'm in Hong Kong they've been
using telegram and telegram has actually
come up with new features to help Oregon
Health them organize in the States stay
secure during the the organizing of
their protests so in in Hong Kong they
have a bunch of different telegram
channels that tell people that they
spread flyers they tell people what's
happening and you know you do also have
to realize that of course people are
gonna get into those and try to spread
propaganda or you know fake information
they've had issues where you know they
have police creating their own telegram
groups and then trying to spread false
information that way and it's funny
because they actually figured it out
because they were using Mandarin instead
of Cantonese
I was gonna ask you are you planning to
be covering the 2020 election campaigns
in a similar way to the way you covered
2016 yeah it'll probably be more more in
March in depth because 2016 I was mostly
talking to people and writing the
occasional article and doing mostly
photojournalism this time we're gonna be
doing a lot more video interviews with
people and yeah it's gonna be a lot more
in-depth I look forward to watching that
that'd be very interesting and what do
you make of of the situation now I mean
I'm a by British standards in the center
politically and I look at what the
Democrats are talking about and I'd vote
for Donald Trump over any of them I
would know any of them I mean I drew
yang and Tulsi Gabbard the kind of
outsiders and if they were to do well
which at this point seems unlikely then
they'd certainly get my vote but you
know Elizabeth Warren talking about the
rights of transgender Mexican illegal
immigrants you just like it's not where
ordinary people are at what do you make
of the the stay of the Democratic Party
and and upcoming 2020 elections yeah
there's the they've got a big battle
coming up and the question is like who
can actually stand a chance against
Donald Trump and I mean I've got my
opinion of who I don't think stands a
chance and it's it's really it comes
down to is it's somebody who's gonna
play his game is that somebody who's
gonna play the populism card or is it
somebody who's gonna try to rise above
it is it gonna be is the DNC gonna make
the same mistake and try to rig it for
their establishment candidate and are
they not like you would assume they'd be
smart enough to know that this is in
Canada at this point is it Joe Biden
yes support helps yes but I don't think
it's just by I think they're still
waiting to figure out who their
establishment candidate is because I
don't think Biden you know even though
he's pulling pretty high right now I
just don't think people think I can win
I think there's a lot of
I think whoever's gonna win needs to be
able to pull back the votes that went
from Democrat to trump last time or not
even to trump but people who just didn't
want to vote for Hillary or who'd just
voted against Hillary because I was a
huge issue like there were so many
people who just didn't want Hillary for
a lot of reasons and I think if the if
the Democrats can't understand that
they're doomed to the same mistakes and
so I think whoever it has a chance is
going to have to be able to take some of
those those votes that went to trump
either out of protest or out of economic
reasons that the Democrats were ignoring
so I think it's it's not going to
necessarily be a the person who stands
chance isn't necessarily going to be
pretty far left I don't think I don't
think Americans in general will get on
board with that however we're talking
about doom to make the same mistakes is
it fair to say that they're making the
same mistakes all over again in fact
they seem to be making them harder yeah
it blows me away it's like they they
either don't want to learn or they're
just clinging to what little they have
left I don't know I think they are gonna
make a lot of the same mistakes because
they're just so used to their status quo
I'm curious there's probably a or nine
candidates currently in the race I think
better of Talisman
okay yeah so you talk about bringing
back the voters who either didn't vote
voted for Donald Trump conventionally
the argument has been the Bernie Sanders
speaks to a lot of those people actually
you know in the Rust Belt etc he's just
had heart attack I'm not sure you come
back from that journey of a presidential
election campaign yeah so who are these
people that you think might bring some
of those people back
I think yang is hitting a lot of the
economic issues that people care about
I think Tulsi is hitting a lot of the
foreign policy issues that people care
about this is like a centrist bubble
right here
I think Bernie Sanders hits a lot of
also economic issues but I think people
aren't necessarily going to agree with
him on some of the social stance that
social issue stance does he takes I
think I mean in America it's just this
whole this whole health care system
thing is it's a mess like I don't think
anybody really knows what they want out
of it and they're scared of taxes going
up they don't know if it's gonna work
and it's it's it's a mess so I don't I
really don't know who would be the one
other than like people who can can speak
to the same economic issues that Trump
was talking about well let me put you on
the spot before we ask a final question
which is it sounds to me like you think
Donald Trump's gonna win again I think I
think he's in a pretty good position to
if if the Democrats make the same
mistakes yet and penultimate question
final question I know it's a bit of a
tricky one but how should the Democrats
attack Trump I don't think they should
focus on attacking Trump honestly I
think they they give him more power that
way I think they've got it I don't want
to say ignore him because you don't want
to ignore somebody who's in a position
of power who can you know you can do a
lot of do a lot of make a lot of moves
that make a lot of changes and can
affect a lot of people but I don't think
attacking him is the way to address the
problems and to actually get support
behind the other other side it's like I
remember which cartoon I remember
watching where there was just a monster
and the more Rockets you fired to him
the bigger he got
we are nothing if not an intellectual
channel anyway we've got one more
question for Emily which is the same
question we asked you all I guess which
is what is the one thing that no one is
talking about that we should be talking
about and you took a deep breath as I
said there's I mean there's just a lot
in general with I mean a lot of the
stuff that I cover is just as social
movements things that the US media
doesn't tend to cover a lot but it
sounds like you're having a lot of
conversations with people who who talk
about these things
I think it's for the most part there's I
mean I can talk to what a u.s. audience
probably would want to hear more about
and that's kind of issues with lower
economic class and how they're they're
being largely ignored by certain
political it's not just America though
yeah like things like addiction the
pharmaceutical industry like really
messing people's lives up is it's a
really huge issue and that's actually
one that I really want to tackle going
forward in my work well we look forward
to seeing that and if people want to
follow you and your work with subversive
this news where do they go for that um
so sub brittany's is add-on submersed on
twitter it's also youtube.com slash
subversive they can follow me at mom's
Molly on Twitter mo mes mo LOI and yeah
I mean we've also got a website
subversive where they can see our videos
and our articles and catch up with our
coverage and keep an eye on it well
thanks for coming on the show and we're
gonna follow your work very closely keep
up with it
thanks for watching guys we'll see you
in a week's time another brilliant
episode take care see you next week
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word